hey guys I wanted to do an update on a
recent video that I did entitled omega-3
fatty acids in can sardines this is part
two now in the first video I talked
about how heat destroys omega-3 fatty
acids because DHA and EPA which are
omega-3 fatty acids are very sensitive
to oxygen and heat and when you can
things you heat them and a lot of times
manufacturing companies will reheat it
with high temperatures up to five hours
after they initially pasteurize it okay
really making sure everything is
completely dead just to preserve it
especially when you do meats okay so
when I initially research this I found
that anytime you can anything you
destroy these omega-3 fatty acids
however I had a little attention the
fact that I personally have not tested
this out I base this off of secondhand
information so I recently hired a third
party lab and I send out two random
samples one a can of sardines and the
others a can of tuna to evaluate how
much omega-3 fatty acids were in these
canned products and I was positive that
it was going to come out zero
what was I wrong okay this actually
shocked me so the sardines had a DHA of
788 milligrams and EPA of 742 milligrams
that's a significant amounts of night
omega-3 fatty acids and in the sample of
canned tuna we had 57 milligrams of DHA
and 41 milligrams of EPA and another
interesting point are the sardines the
sardines were 13 times higher in DHA
than the tuna and the EPA was 18 times
higher than the EPA of tuna and these
are omega-3 fatty acids which is
interesting so the only way this makes
sense to me is they probably don't use
the high level of heat of other products
like canned meats so anyway I will be
deleting the other video and I wanted
you to have the correct updated
information that it is true that canned
sardines and
do have omega-3 fatty acids thanks for
watching so I'm doing a survey for
future videos on topics that you are
interested in this one is going to be on
your biggest keto difficulty if you
wouldn't mind filling out the survey
down below I put a link in the
description please fill it out thank you
so much